Hi there.
Hi, sorry about that.
I guess it said it's finishing at 12.30 and that's what I
No, it's all good, totally okay.
How are you doing?
Great.
How are you?
Nice to meet you.
Yeah, yeah, nice to meet you too. Thanks for taking
time. Of course. Of course. Thanks for
doing this for us. Yeah, yeah, exactly.
I want to make sure that
you and Jess feel like you're getting what you need.
instead of something that is like might sound cool.
but isn't necessarily going to be useful for you in the long term.
like last time we tried to do this.
- Oh yeah, is that what you're doing?
what happened? Well, I think the person that
that helped us out.
Thought Kajabi was a good platform to solve
our problem but did not know how to use it.
herself. So she spent
most of her time learning.
And then sort of trying to
teach us how to use it with
It was obviously didn't work out very well because
Right. We've totally switched our.
direction and our plan and.
And we're not able to get members.
So.
That's a problem.
Yeah, yeah, of course.
Okay. Is there...
I suggest has given me some of this context as well.
Is there a--
or anything else that's just kind of off the top of your head, that is.
your current state that you want to talk through.
No, I think you're familiar with what we're dealing with.
really my biggest concern is
access and security.
Yep.
So we really wanted to do a way.
with fees so that we can
just blow it wide open and there's no
restriction. That said, like I said,
mentioned to you we are a purely Jewish
for women and.
with the state of the world right now, security is a
real issue and in spammers and all that kind of.
stuff happens. So I just want to
to make sure that like.
We're going to be in conversation.
directly with people while working.
trying to encourage them to join.
However,
If we put an event, you know, if people...
register. So okay let's say they put a password.
or whatever it is and we have the information.
I want a secondary method.
mechanism like I I don't care if there's a
I want to be able to somehow
see who's in there.
So I don't know if that's possible.
but and then really for them just to be able to
like, okay, we have an event, we know how to post.
it. We know how to have the link. We know how to send it.
it out if we need to send an email if we want.
I'm going to do a blog post.
I'm going to.
start on a podcast soon and I think
jobby handle that so I wasn't
sure for now I was looking at some
because I didn't know if we should integrate it.
like we were very nervous about adding more.
things. So.
That's kind of the next phase.
is and then what do we do about Wix like our
website. Right.
Okay. And I saw the way.
I just walked me through that as well and it seems like
right now. The main function for Wix is as
a donation platform like it connects to Zephi.
Is that correct?
Yeah, so
We were using it as before as an image.
information, like just a landing page almost.
Yeah, before we had kajabi we put our
events on there and it was
super easy. People could sign up, they could pay.
right there. The money went into our account.
And it was pretty simple.
Are you familiar with both of you?
of these? Yeah, I am.
So what's your...
advice. Yeah. Take the money aside.
and the complexity aside.
In terms of
functionality. What what a.
is a better route for us.
to go.
consolidating all of this.
outreach and all of the public.
outreach that you're doing in Kajabi is the way.
Kajabi does indeed have a l-
of the functionality that you're looking for. It does have that podcast.
module. It's got the blog section and what I
what I'm seeing as I'm looking there is.
The way that the previous developer who worked with
with you had set it up is everything is kind of locked.
under this product page for like juke juke.
jubling insider which I understand
and kind of gating the access to a certain extent.
but it's cutting off your nose to spite your face.
phase what's happening here in here.
- Well, I think the problem
was that we had it was a
fee-based membership before. So she
I wanted to sort of sort separate out
who were paid members and who were
free like what was just open to the public but yeah.
It feels like we're very stuck.
Right and what I was seeing and
as I was going through just the architecture you have set up in Kajabi.
right now is that it is pretty simple to just train.
transfer the various parts that currently
exist from Wix into Kajabi.
To have that landing page that you're talking about but also
to have the various
Ways that people can engage on the web.
but then there's automations that can be created through
through Kajabi that will help to really
create a pipeline for outbound
and inbound communication that are quite simple.
to set up. It's just a matter of having somebody who knows
how to doing it. And so that's what I've kind of like laid out.
here is a fairly straightforward.
feedback loop between you and your friends.
in your members.
- Okay, yeah, because that's a...
other pieces. For instance, this afternoon,
I met someone who
said, oh, my sister is a senior executive this--
is perfect for her. So I said, great.
Now, you know, the next thing is like...
to get her to somehow go to.
jubling.org.
- Yeah.
Not kajabi because nobody knows what kajabi is.
which is another issue is when things come.
It comes out from Kajabi.
I don't know if there's a workaround for that, but we sort of
of lose our identity in there.
So that's number one and then so we
We want them to go to the website, but then I can't--
convert them from there.
especially now if I don't have a membership.
membership was the mechanism. Okay. Right. But now.
look, how do I keep them and how do I keep them?
I know that somebody even came and looked as a visitor.
I want to be a wholesome data.
on that so we can you know reach out with an email.
over here and a contact. But I don't know if it has
has that capability like a landing page and a.
- It does. - It does. Okay.
We keep paying more and more money and upgrading our--
thing and we I don't know
Yeah.
I think what you've...
got it at this point is you have access to all of
this functionality. Now it's just a matter of actually
kind of.
reaching your arms out into it and it
It's like the reason that I would be happy to take this.
and donate is one I want to support the mission.
but this is exactly the kind of thing that
is you just need to do it once and
have that structure set up. And then with
Within a platform like Kajabi, it will just start to run.
itself at a certain point. But having somebody who is
already busy with a million other things.
like you and Jess are is kind of the key here. So.
Yeah, the biggest thing that I can do.
from talking to Jessica say from the websites and the the weeks
and the distribution happening is just the--
The flow of the joining process.
just making that very easy.
You have the.
jubling.org domain it sounds like so all we have to do
is just point the Kajabi website to
the domain or vice versa, like when they use the domain it
It will bring up the Kajabi site, but there doesn't have to be a
be this confusing.
layer of bureaucracy that's coming from Kajal.
That is all easy to...
I should...
is that easy. It is possible to set that up.
easy for you possible.
It's easy when you have the time.
Do you?
Do we need to keep?
Keep wicks.
Is that I don't see a reason
to do that at this point. I think it's a hat on a hat.
to have both.
People could go to jubling.org.
it would take them right to Kajabi.
instead of through wicks.
- Yes.
Okay, we do own the juby-
that's fine and thank you for finding out
that our site was down the other day.
What is that?
I mean you see there's
nobody even uses it so like nobody even noticed even
including us unless somebody wants to give us money.
Right. Zephy, we're gonna keep Zephy and Zephy.
can go right through from Kajabi.
- Yep.
- We wanna do, we wanna, because we're...
open membership up to be free.
So when when people come in and we onboard them
them. So there's certain places we really want to put
that we need to know who wants to go into these.
ongoing learning.
groups that we have, autumn kaburos.
there, whoever wants to go into these groups.
So we need some kind of feedback.
back to know to reach out to them because it really
manual setup. You can't just do that. Yeah, right.
That's fine.
And then...
And if they want to pay, if they want to make a, you know,
voluntary donation instead of a fee.
that needs to be there as part of the onboarding process.
- Yep.
- And then obviously to...
point them next. I'll change all those videos and
whatever we have on there depending on what our
flow needs to be, where they need to go next, how they're going to be.
need to access things.
And then from a login.
perspective. Like we have an
event. Let's say that's out there. I put it
on WhatsApp to our members and say, "Hey,
this is out there or it goes through email and somebody clicks
on that link. Right now it's going to assign it.
page for name and effort.
But it doesn't say what if you forgot?
got your password like it just I don't know.
Yeah.
not a friendly first place to go.
And I'm...
What I'll do is I'll kind of walk through that workflow.
of just like what happens when you click the various things.
that are posted up here, but what I'm hoping...
is the case is just by architecting
various things within the...
modules that Kajabi has on picture here like the sidebar.
on the left that has all the different things there that.
I think what has been created up until this point.
point is essentially like a like worker.
rounds that can technically get
Members to events can technically get people to be...
demonstrating interest, but it's not working within the
the framework that Kajabi offers you.
So all of the things that you just articulated are
very achievable within this.
set up here. It's just a matter of like diversifying.
the way is that people...
the ways that you're collecting information from people.
and the ways that people are going to act.
access things like what I noticed in your own.
in the member section, the member point.
there was a lot of overlap.
between the different events and you have distinct
events, it is possible to segment
that out like you were talking about learning so there's a courses
within Kajabi as well. I think that's kind of a big...
selling point with KnoB. And so we'll get to be in.
revenue generator. Like we give things
We'll give you the membership for free so certain things come from
for free, but if we do a professional development
course on public speaking or I don't
strategic planning, like, take that and.
And if you're signed up as a member, you can get a discount.
now but don't have the fee.
So like--
How do we monetize this?
and because you know Jess and I need to get paid and so.
God forbid right?
That's why you're doing it.
We know we're, you know,
or someday.
And we're doing the right thing.
That's all we need.
- Yes.
(laughs)
Yes.
That is all very doable with
in Kajabi, I think in a lot of ways that
This is all meant to be history.
If it's free, then there's still--
information gating that you're getting from your users.
that enables you to market, that's nothing is free anymore.
kind of a situation and that's totally fine.
That's how that's the world that we are.
But then yes, you can have those.
those pancakes that make it very clear and like, here's
what's part of the experience of just coming to the website and just be
a free member, but then here's where you got a call.
up and it'll be easier to un-
understand the distinction between, well, I'm a member.
How does that jive with the...
things that are being offered as any products are served.
So you said it up before was like this
insider and then a free and so
What if I'm part of all of them because I want them?
that's there and something that's there and it are
Our members just like forget it.
You know, and our engagement went down.
completely different things that we were doing and
And yeah, it was very frustrating for people.
I'm sure.
Okay.
Well, the good news is that all of the things that you're talking about.
about are completely doable with
and Kajabi and within the scope that I had, you know,
time box within three or so with three weeks.
completely possible within that period of time.
Okay. Have you.
before with with Kajabi or you
you're just like savvy enough.
Smart enough to figure it out.
It's a little bit of--
Both I hadn't used literally Kajabi before,
but I...
I've used Squarespace, I've used Mailchimp.
I've done newsletters and designs for companies.
before he's just using like they're all just they're
They're all pigs at the same trough.
They're all just trying to...
offer something somewhat different one.
But the job is sort of, it's...
those are like, I want to say plug it.
right? Where's Abby tries to be a-
community space, like it wants people to have a conversation.
and you know and we would love to do
that if we could make it easily accessible.
and get rid of our WhatsApp group and just have the
that as a, you know, have a link to something that's
going on or here's the conversation.
be an extra and kajabi be the community.
space versus the other way around. People are
frustrated they can't get in so they go and have a conversation.
What's that?
Right.
Yeah.
And I was seeing--
on the member page that there's a feed where
you can have that almost like Facebook or
LinkedIn style ongoing discussion between
members, but it was just limited to things that you were
posting. So again that functionality is there.
and you'll get even more of a feedback.
back loop if friends are seeing friends or other members put
and sharing things and giving each other comments.
feedback. So yeah, it that is different.
about Kajabi, but it's...
fairly straightforward how it comes together.
- Okay.
And what do you think about this whole security thing?
Do you need--
to get in there and see it first to see.
how like how do we block people?
How do we...
So the the way that I
have my own personal website set up and and I handle
this just earlier this week, excuse me.
is through CloudFlare, which have you heard of?
cloud flare before. Yeah, but I don't know how it's
It's not a like, are you a robot?
thing or the yes yeah they that's one
of the layers of security that they'll implement if you
But the reason that you set up with something like that.
like Cloud Fire versus GoDaddy is if you
are trying to harden your security around.
your website more intentionally.
That being said, it's free to
have the CloudFlare subscription, the only thing that I'm paying for.
for me personally is the domain. That's just
running through Cloudflare. You have that through GoDaddy.
have to switch anything and now it's just a matter of
getting the kind of technical...
details like the DNS and secure socket.
player, how did that be within CloudFlare rather than go
Daddy, the alternative, Marcy, is that I can...
Look at your go daddy account and if all that's there
If it's all possible to just switch
things on or to configure it closer to
what you're looking for, then we don't have to change anything on the...
Yeah, I think that's what happened when I... that's how I...
we shut down our email or website this week.
I hit one of those. It was like change this thing.
in the DNS setting of like, what that means.
I thought you could tell me, just go here and do the...
And I'm like, I don't know what that means.
Now it's so easy to accidentally flip the line.
light switch off. So yeah, I can bother.
There's me. It's like
sites, you know, I get it because they want you to.
use their service.
Like, you know, I'm a business consumer.
all that. I get how this works. It's about money and business.
But everybody seems to be.
have their own language.
like, oh, you just need to go there and do this.
Well, but there it goes.
language isn't saying the same thing that you're saying.
So it's...
Yeah, so if you want to deal with all of that, sure.
We're very happy to have you take that on.
Yes, yeah, that will be kind of
part of the first phase is sort of getting the latest
of the land, not just out of the jubling, could you obviously say what you're doing?
which I have at this point, but looking at what you have.
on the technical side, seeing if they're really--
is anything that needs to change because it's
also possible that the kind of security that you
want out of this platform is already being admired.
Minister through GoDaddy, I just need to verify that.
at first, and if GoDaddy for whatever reasons not able to
offer it, then we'll look at pivoting it.
to another service and that's what I would handle as well.
And also with Wix, if we get rid of that site, that's
fine. We just put that up there when we first.
launched we needed something.
I built that site.
- Right.
- I'm not a web developer.
So I don't know.
You know, we just sort of put stuff in there to have information.
Yeah, I don't care where it is and
and it doesn't hurt my feelings if we get rid of it.
Hopefully we'll get some money back from it, but sure.
just like as we can keep this as simple.
It's so interesting.
We're talking about business women. They're used to this. They do.
with technology, but this is in their
personal. It's not professional.
development, it's personal.
And so this frusta
them to know and in their personal life.
I don't want to do something on my time.
And I have layers and layers and I have to put in this and I can't find.
right? If they just they go no.
We don't want to be part of it.
I get it because your code switching in your head.
I'm not--
not doing work on my computer where I'm having to deal with.
with my CRM and God knows what else,
but I can expect
that that's part I'm getting paid to do that.
And in my networking group, I wanted to be a--
simple as Instagram or Facebook or whatever.
whatever the community uses.
I get it. I can see why that would happen.
Right, and so they just don't engage with it.
Okay.
but it's a very necessary...
Yes.
We hear it all.
everybody we talk to. This is amazing.
This is so important, like in our community,
to give women.
this support, this love out these features.
But again, it's a...
It's a nice to do.
It's not a...
of must do and in their personal time.
their personal time as mothers and wives and running
house over and above their jobs which are demanding.
because they're in business.
So.
if it's going to cause them any kind of...
Forget it. They're not doing it. So right that's where we're
holding, especially Jess because she's sort of the...
She gets to be the leader.
lead on those pieces.
And--
If she can't figure it out, a smart, invisible item.
she is. Yeah, you know.
So yeah, okay, what do you need from us with
What do you need to do next?
the Kajabi login from Jess. She said that this morning.
I do.
I think.
I would benefit from having your wicks log in and having
access to GoDaddy.
as well as Zafi, basically, zoom as well. Any...
thing that is going to be part of this
app website ecosystem.
I think sending that over to me the way that I
secure them RC just for your own comfort is I use one.
password is a password vault. I don't say
I don't write things down.
It is
And yeah, so it'll be secure.
the vault that I maintain.
And I will also...
I'm also happy to delete them and send
and proof to you that I've gotten rid of the credentials
after the fact.
Okay, GoDaddy has
has my business information in there.
as well for my own website.
So if you see it, you'll just, you'll...
you'll see there's jubling and then there's that.
- Okay.
and zoom. I have a sheet.
I'll just take a picture on it.
I have everything. - Okay.
What else would you need from us?
I think.
At some point and I think that this is something that
would best be managed by you directly.
At some point I might hit...
to get where they're like, hey, please connect your bank account for a blog.
a bloke for whatever service like I will hand that
to you that is obviously something that you can handle.
- Right.
just let you know when that happens.
- Also,
because I'm eight, seven hours ahead of you.
If you're gonna be doing something, I'm free.
available but I'm seven hours ahead of you.
So if you're doing something that's going to need a code.
And that load is going to come to me.
Just like coordinate that with me.
Yeah, I'll plan to time that.
Okay.
Yeah, my late-life.
my sleep schedule has me up at 4.30 every day.
And so that actually probably works out well in terms of--
I didn't talk about too cool.
Yeah.
- Yeah, I mean, yeah, I'm around and I work.
- Cool.
I work late. So because we're on a
Merit. We're with
We have our own full day and then we have an American day.
So we work later.
But usually I'm around if you can't you have my phone
like literally call me and say, "Hey, I need this."
code. Okay.
Okay, good.
Excited.
Now, in terms of
images or images or images or images or images or images.
of that kind of stuff.
as much as we can.
told us that you could.
couldn't really customize that without
an extra membership or call.
like I don't really know what you'll see when you're
when you go into it.
- Yeah.
- You don't even know what we have.
We got it.
expanded product.
last year I think we upgraded it because
we needed to have multiple admin.
access before we could only have one.
instead of me needing to chase Jess and find her
if I needed to get into the site. So we just paid
I don't know, $500 or whatever.
We got this upgraded.
Honestly, Tim, we have no idea what we have.
We really don't.
We're trusting.
Because you know
Got it. Yeah, so as far as...
This image goes, I did want to quickly just touch on it.
that I could obviously see like the purple.
like I try to incorporate that in the proposal that I sent to you.
and happy to maintain that.
a lot of that color scheme was
carrying through and the stock images that was being used.
for the events. Is that all?
stuff that you would want to maintain.
Yeah.
I mean, just make those images an AI.
You know, we have
Our women are...
They dress most of the artist and really are.
to get any images so we have to create them.
Yeah. One time I put a...
I put in chat GPT and it gave me pictures of all the...
Amish women with a... with a...
people on their head, you know, a sculpt out.
And I was like, yeah, that's not, no, okay.
So, oh.
Along those lines though, that makes sense about using the...
the AI and just and I talked about that.
a lot when she and I will work together.
You notice that a lot of the women that would come through in the AIG.
generated stuff. They look like shiksa women and they're not
your community. Right. Recess.
So from the standpoint--
of like how can we try to maintain that representation?
that you're looking for while still kind of striking the madness.
balance. So...
Anything that we run together, any
imagery or whatever, I can run that by you and Jess.
I'll...
set it up in a place where it's easy so we can look at it asynchronously.
honestly, because I'm...
I'm the Gentile, I'm outside the community.
will do everything that I can to to maintain.
in the identity, but I don't need it to be--
I don't think we needed to be women necessarily.
- Okay.
I think if it's a business image,
if it's a business image,
if it's, I don't know.
like some of us, but we're not, we're not.
we're not hung up on that. Like, right, we're in business.
And we're, it just, I wanted to just be,
aesthetically attractive.
I want people to enjoy the site.
I wanted to
be comfortable. I want it to be have
something that draws them in.
but it doesn't have to be with me.
in every image.
Yeah, I'm thinking of what you're doing.
you're putting down. Yeah, I think feminine is a good angle.
take, but it doesn't have to be that literal. So yes.
I think I can. I don't know what that really can be.
It can be a beautiful...
nature picture it can be like something that's
thing it can be images it can be like
It doesn't have to be...
And it doesn't have to be computers because it's
business and right.
Yeah, yeah, no, I think I could strike that balance. There's
There's plenty in God's creation so that we don't have to just do one.
Okay. Okay.
open, we just we really just wanted to work and be
easy experience for
our people. So I'm going to get you this information.
I'll send it over to you in a minute.
Okay.
It's probably just going to be a screenshot of a doctor.
that I have with everything on it.
doesn't work just let me know.
Yeah, since you are working and you will be...
sending that to me, I will immediately kind of pressure test.
of the logins just to make sure that I have access to
it and then I'll just ping you if I need anything.
Great, so I'll stand by in case anybody's...
There's codes or anything as you get in.
Yeah, I get it over here.
I get questions about everything because now I'm not in the US.
anymore. So it's like we had a, you know,
have somebody trying to get into your camp from Israel.
Yeah.
I know.
Yeah, they're trying to reconcile on your phone number.
areas and all that. I don't know how they determine it but yes.
Well, it's interesting the IP address.
So I use all my names.
American identification still for everything.
I have an American phone number, but it picks me up.
up certain sites, it automatically deepens.
fall to Israel or Hebrew if I go into a certain
Okay.
And I'm like, wow, that's really interesting.
Because I don't do that.
specifically do that, but it does it.
Another quirk that I noticed that.
is just something I wanted to do.
clear up with you over the phone is I noticed
that on some of the Kajabi pages or might have been on the Wixby
pages. The text was like a lot.
to the right and I know that Hebrew reads right to the right.
left but that I mean this is English tech
next for American users, right?
So like...
That's just something messed up.
Yeah, no. Okay.
No reason whatsoever. Okay
Now, got it.
S- simpler than it looks.
The explanation is simpler than it looks at you.
- No, it's funny.
We have
We have, in Jewish law,
You know, we have a lot of
very finite little details.
And there's so many stories.
where there are a group of people and they took on a certain
something and you ask them why?
And they go, I don't know. We just we saw you know, we
I saw the rabbi do it and so like a whole roommate and they go
Well, why didn't you do it?
Well, because it was just easier.
like it's the end.
They're saying but we have to ask questions.
because sometimes it's not really
an explanation. It's just a mistake.
or a right. This happened.
Yeah, like I imagine if there's a...
There was some rabbi like...
millennia ago who was left handed and it was just
easier to write from my left hand Senate.
the other way. Right.
Something like that.
Okay, good to know.
So yeah, so if you have questions.
It's about that. It's probably not.
Intentional, just something we did.
Okay, all right. I think I have everything that I need.
Thank you so much. I'm excited to work with you.
And good luck.
Yeah, thank you likewise. This will be fun.
Yeah, okay. We'll be in touch.
Okay, thank you.
- Bye.